peu
que vous n'êtes vivre durant quelques
secondes
est ce que j'ai vécu durant 38 ans voire
l'élève de mes interlocuteurs bouger
sans avoir la moindre idée de ce qu'il
me disait
et le pire c'est que je ne disais rien
de maturité par peur du rejet qui n'a
pas rêvé un jour de se déconnecter
temporairement dans un environnement
bruyant
pour moi la nature m'a offert ce luxe à
la naissance
sauf que ce n'est pas temporaire
longtemps j'ai préféré laisser penser
que je ne comprenais pas plutôt qu'à
vous et que j'étais mal entendants il
m'est arrivé à de nombreuses reprises
catalogué comme pas très intelligent
c'était dans le meilleur des cas avec
des gens plutôt bienveillant va
provoquer des quiproquos parfois
complexes
que vous ne pouvez même pas imaginer on
ne comprenait pas ce que l'on me disait
et du coup j'ai j'ai préféré arrêter
dans cette situation-là de doute sa
nature et sa durée très longtemps vous
allez vous en conflit les gens qui
considérait que j'étais stupide
plus tard je n'ai pas d'avis là dessus
c'était une vérité mais en tous les cas
c'était les gens qui tombent
bienveillant le camp quand j'ai commencé
on peut déjà avancer dans la vie sur ce
sujet d'armes
effectivement j'ai essayé de rentrer en
contact de me reconnecter la surdité
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
forcément visible en tous les cas pas ou
premier rapport par contre c'est quelque
chose qui a tous surpris un jour ou
l'autre vous avez tous quelqu'un dans
votre entourage qui est dans cette
situation et qui ne comprend pas
forcément ce que vous avez qui va
laisser pourrir énormément que si vous
aurez parfois ça à d'autres
à ce prix c'est sur la socialisation
par exemple je n'ai pas fait la
maternelle gp la maternelle lui le
premier jour où n'ayant pas compris la
consigne d'aller me rendre à la cantine
pour le déjeuner gtx étaient rentrés
chez eux donc trois ans j'ai fait deux
kilomètres la campagne personne ne
m'attendait pas parce que j'étais
comptabilisée pour la traque à la
cantine
petit machin comme ça partout et j'étais
mûr à trois ans ma mère était
traumatisée par par l'événement le
village était sens dessus dessous
imaginez et donc du coup ma mère ne m'a
jamais revenu à l'école maternelle
donc j'ai au moins des naissains avait
perturbé par une maturité a pu tenter
pour me faire barils donc on rappelle
qu'on est dans les années 75 77 64 65
je me souviens le premier appareillage
que j'ai tenté qui était loin d'être
celui qu'on peut connaître aujourd'hui
donc en attente c'est le walkman n'a pas
encore été inventé lee les autres gros
écouteurs que vous voyez dans le métro
ne sont pas encore à la mode
moi je r complexé et je vous parle à
personne même pas à ma famille pour moi
c'est un déni de dignité à l'école si
vous souvenez vous projetez pour
certains
donc sur cette époque-là aller à l'école
jean-du-nord devinette
on l'appelle des dinos car pouvant
frapper les souffre douleur de ceux qui
sont plus costaud plus du guide et et du
coup je me dis pas je ne suis pas encore
fort jeudi disant je ne sens pas capable
d'affronter le regard de l'autre en me
disant je vais me balader avec une sauce
neige sur la tête toute la journée avec
un tuyau qui va dans l'oreille et dit je
préfère à la rigueur passé pour stupide
d'avoir cet axe et heurte à la tête
c'est comme ça que j'avais vécu à ce
moment là ensuite j'ai eu une scolarité
plutôt chaotique
quand vous n'entendez pas grand chose de
ce que le prof c'est plus compliqué à
noter encore plus à restituer par contre
j'ai fait mon service militaire alors la
route mais pas de moi moi je voulais
faire votre activité
elle ne voulait pas de moi parce que
c'est un risque que pour elle de prendre
un sourd cavale en tentant parc ont tiré
avec des fusils toqué de voulait agua
j'étais le fou de l'âme de réformer dans
tous les cas je ne quittais pas les
trois jours ce qu'on appelle côté trois
jours pour être non pas connu aucune ne
vais pas signer le papier
j'ai eu le tampon aux actes
effectivement mais le gp de service par
leurs foulées souletines parachutistes
m'ont fait qu'aucun des camions et des
bus n'a quitté l'armée et ça ça me
rendait dingue
les copains de chambrée pour se faire
réformer beaucoup
l'époque les animaux ni terme et tout le
monde cherche à se réformer et moi le
seul mois que j'étais réformable tout de
suite
j'étais dans le cas par cas aux
capacités d'une paternité
moi j'ai insisté préfèrent ils ne
comprenaient pas les gens réputés les
saleuses service que je voulais faire je
voulais juste être pour une fois comme
tes neurones
donc j'étais largué des armes et ensuite
dans le bourg j'ai aussi rendu compte
assez rapidement que la réussite créer
le contact
la connexion l'envié d'aller les autres
et cette acceptation enfin d autres m'a
fait avec eux que j'ai toujours dit être
dans les premiers dans chacun des jobs
que j'ai occupés à ce canton du premier
du coup le handicap c'est un et surtout
jeudi malentendants je dis souvent quand
on voit un souhait du malade soit la
couleur je voulais pas cumuler en fait
le fait d'être maintenant aux nuls et
surtout je ne voulais pas prendre
prétexte de nationalité pour avoir des
résultats médiocres
donc c'est une vie professionnelle qui
était plutôt pas trop mal passé ensuite
j'ai en 2003 je rentre d'un voyage en
alsace et je sais que mes filles pour
deux ans et demi et trois ans et demi à
une salariée admis que nous dans leur
cerveau et je m'arrête tout à coup
brusquement sur le bas côté
ça surprend
je m'effondre je pleure je craque
complètement ma fille cadette tant que
de faire passer un message on me pose
une question en fait et je ne comprends
pas c'est maintenant elle est une fois
deux fois trois fois été fisée voilà que
je veux faire ça c'est déclenchèrent
télé 3d me dis que je peux je peux j'ai
toujours assumé jusque là le fait de
passer par stupide dans les
conversations
le fait de compter considère à ce moment
là parce que j'avais pas interpréter
comme il fallait un lego signaux et ne
pas comprendre mes propres qui met
devant leurs enfants peut-être pour moi
c'était en question donc ça a déclenché
une volonté de tout faire pour venir à
paris entre 2003 2009 plusieurs
tentatives vaines de d'appareillage avec
des appareils
ça ne fonctionne pas comme il faut par
rapport à maturité en 2009 j'étais coque
déterminés à y arriver je trouve un
programme expérimental américain qui
fait des essais en europe parce que trop
coûteux aux états unis sur une
technologie d'un plan interne qui sont
en train de
lancé sur le marché ils ont besoin de
cette cobayes je fais partie et je serai
le deuxième le premier français est le
deuxième but à recevoir cette
technologie mais avant avant d'en
arriver là les mâles et retisse bien ils
me disent mais attention c'est
irréversible on coup c'est pas juste un
implant propose et au cou à l'intérieur
on ouvre on passe de temps au goût et au
cou donc vous n'avez plus la possibilité
de revenir à la situation antérieure
une fois coupé ressources hijab et zen
contiennent pas et ewan mais convaincu
un peu dehors j'ai très envie de tenter
l'expérience
dans ce cas là alors pas sa pression pas
mal de choses et je me suis je ne veux
pas prononcé de cette chance quels que
soient les risques et que toute façon je
ne risque pas sincèrement je risque de
perdre les cinq ans qui viennent parce
que de toute façon la vocation de ma
surdité des progrès si opérateur
alternatif c'est de toute façon à terme
être sourd donc je risque ces cinq ans
et toute façon sa voleuse nous avons là
ça vaut le coup de tenter cette
expérience secrète est costaud je suis
fort la vie m'a endurci je vais être
capable d'assumer en cas d'échec et
l'avenir ne durera que finalement tout
en cuir d'enrobé que je peux être
finalement c'est pas aussi simple que ça
en fait des locations est un échec
ca c
c'est une des possibilités est pas la
plus probable mais était une des
possibilités dur pourtant j'avais bien
pris soin de réfléchir de mesurer le
sujet et là je me bats ou de base est
forgé la famille heureusement des amis
et ça m'a souri
mais c'est vrai que à ce moment là
j'avais envie de tout abandonner une
situtation genton période les
chirurgiens et le laboratoire ne veulent
pas retenté l'opération parce que c'est
un peu notre problème technique et
d'assurance et potentiellement récupéré
par tenter un coup plus tard après avoir
insisté être débattue et a fini par
accepter de réimplanter l'appareil et la
succès jour pour jour le 18 juin 2010
succès là je commence à entendre à être
vrai voilà ce que j'ai dans la tête
alors attention on le tue sans site ça
n'est pas à l'échelle des foyers deux
filles 1 qu'il se positionne derrière le
tympan qui sert de micro et l'autre qui
donne une leçon est apprêté par le
processeur jusqu'au cerveau est lui par
contre compte augmenter sa ne pas
impacter le cerveau aujourd'hui on est
il que je suis un homme augmenté
augmenter parce que j'ai une technologie
effectivement de dater jodar militaires
dans la tête et que ça remplace monneret
complètement l'intérieur on compare à
steve austin steve austin par les
millénium transall qui n'ont pas connu
la terrine qui était l'homme qui valait
trois milliards
c'est un astronaute américain s'est
crashé excusé sur le tarmac et qui a été
reconstruit avec des techniques et
technologies qui à l'époque était
futuriste
c'était technologie là aujourd'hui pour
partie merci le temps que je suis un
homme dziennik havre est un vrai symbole
comme disent certains
j'entends n'ont pu avec une oreille
interne mairie qu'une oreille elle
prenait et une intelligente arthrite et
pas l'interpréter et encore des gens
pour me dire ça valait le coup tout ça
franchement pas ce que tu entends pas
mieux que nous
mais j'entends pour moi c'est déjà
énorme et j'ai derrière moi j'ai quitté
l'île maurice vous pouvoir me baigner
tout est à l'intérieur pouvoir baigner
sans risquer de l'appareil pouvoir
rester branché connectés en gagnant
c'est gênant c'est le courant il
yad'autres conforme
le fait d'avoir la possibilité de faire
des courses sans être embêté parce que
je suis un sou qui peut être sourd à la
commande
je ne les connais j'entends pas les
promotions du magasin
quand je pense que d entendre j'entends
pas le mot nude coranique qui à sa mère
je veux ce juin je peux dormir à côté
d'une voiture est derrière aubin et
surtout je peux dormir à côté d'une
compagnie roches à conserver alors c'est
la situation la situation de la coupe
saute la vraie situation idéale c'est
vrai que les deux technologies group
voilà j'ai tout ça très bien si et
seulement si c'est temporaire
si j'ai une manette aujourd'hui c'est
facile de faire de parler de sa vie
quand il a fallu que j'attende trois
mois pour être reconnecté parce que pour
changer la pile on ouvre l'application
je suis pas dur à singer pas une trappe
donc on ouvre et scénographe au change
et elle m sûr que 45 minutes mais on
louvre j'ai attendu trois mois
oprah mots justes sur devenus sourds
trois mois je me suis reposée des
milliers de questions parce que je ne
savais pas s'il fallait ou pas remettre
la paix nous voilà donc ce que je trois
mois se sont écoulés où j'étais son j'ai
écrit j'ai partagé sur les réseaux
sociaux mon expérience j'ai
des gens incroyables m'ont rappelé mon
écriture soutenue et du coup j'ai pas
lâcher j'ai pas lâcher le gg c'est
participer à une aventure incroyable qui
a été initiée par personne qui a créé et
carew des inconnus sur twitter les
styles sont deux rencontres m'ont
soutenu l'ennemi les dénudent insomnies
j'ai pu être connecté malgré le fait que
j'étais redevenu tsur donc les réseaux
sociaux a été pour moi un atout
indéniable on reprendre du port pour ne
pas laisser tomber le projet pendant
reconnecter et enfin une chose que je
voulais vous dire parce que pour moi
c'est l'expérience que j'ai vécue durant
toutes ces années sur tous ces vingt
dernières années
sama ça va a cru que la connexion est
essentiel c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé
de participer
quand on m'a invité à le faire à ceux
des leaks il ya l'extraordinaire
l'extraordinaire de la reconnexion c'est
vous c'est vous parce que c'est
individuellement quand on fait attention
aux autres et sur twitter pour les
réseaux sociaux toutes été multipliés
c'est cette attention qui vous permet
aujourd'hui d'être plus torités et
d'apporter du bonheur aux autres
merci
[Applaudissements]